سمعنا منا وزيرة الخارجية
لينكولن هناك
كيف ينظر ولي العهد إلى العلاقات
مع واشنطن
الآن في حقبة ما بعد ترامب ،
بشكل جيد ، الخطأ الدقيق الذي كتبه توني
بلينكين مثير جدًا للاهتمام ، أليس
روزماري وأعتقد أنه كان نفس
الشيء هنا  مع ولي العهد
يتحدث إلى التلفزيون السعودي ، كان
يستغل الذكرى السنوية الخامسة
لرؤيته 2030 التي تعد
مخططًا اقتصاديًا لإعادة تعريف
العلاقات مع واشنطن ،
حتى أنني أود أن أضيف هنا في الشرق الأوسط ، كان
محمد بن سلمان يقترح أن
لديهم 90
اتفاقية  مع واشنطن الآن
وهو على استعداد تام للعمل
في العشر الأواخر ، فقد حصل على دعم كامل
كما تعلم من إدارة ترامب
، وتقرير وكالة المخابرات المركزية الذي تحدثت عنه
والذي صدر قبل شهرين
يورط ولي العهد في مقتل جمال
خاشقجي
العلاقات المتوترة  مرة أخرى ، لكن من
الواضح أنهم يريدون تجاوز هذا
الحدبة إذا كنت تريد
تغييرًا جذريًا في النغمة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بإيران بالطريقة التي يقول إنه
لا يفعلها  لا أريد أن تكون
هذه علاقة صعبة مع طهران لكن
يمكن أن تكون
مزدهرة لكنه يقول إن
الطموحات النووية لبرنامج الصواريخ الباليستية
أه التي تسعى إيران لتحقيقها لا يمكن أن تمر
دون رادع وكذلك استخدام
المتمردين الحوثيين بالوكالة هنا
لشن هجمات  إلى المملكة العربية السعودية في
المملكة من الشرق إلى الغرب ، كان هناك
ضغط لا يُصدق على المملكة العربية السعودية على
تلك الجبهة ،
لكن يمكنك سماع التحول الكبير الذي
يريد التعاون معه في المستقبل
وحتى تسوية
الخلاف مع قطر في بداية
العام إلى  أظهر ولكي
يوضح للإدارة
أنه يمكن أن يكون باني جسر
مختلف تمامًا عن لهجته في
ظل إدارة ترامب بالتأكيد.